[Musique]
il y a de plus en plus de gens qui
travaillent pour les plateformes dites
collaboratifs comme hubert hubert eaton
h ce qui est des choses il ya quand même
pas mal de questions qui se posent sur
les conditions de travail de ces
personnes est ce qu'on est en train
d'assister à un effritement des
conditions de travail avec l'émergence
de ce type de plateforme avec nous ce
soir nos loups et de la non professeur
au département de management de
l'université laval bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur fillion il ya beaucoup
de gens qui trouvent leur compte en
quand même dans ce type de plateforme ça
peut donner du travail à bien des gens
avant de parler des enjeux problématique
andy ma question des avantages à
travailler pour des entreprises comme
hubert its d'or dachau ce type de
déchets
oui effectivement il ya un certain
nombre de personnes de par leurs
conditions générales de j qu'ils
trouvent un intérêt à travailler pour ce
type de plateforme donc on peut penser
par exemple aux personnes qui
travaillent ou qui étudient à temps
plein et qui ont besoin simplement d'un
revenu d'appoint des personnes qui ont
un emploi à temps plein mais dont les
revenus ne sont pas suffisants là encore
peuvent aller compléter leurs revenus
puis à toutes sortes de contraintes pour
certaines personnes qui doivent je me
lévy active est rocher d'en avoir la
responsabilité d'enfants etc les jeunes
étudiants donc plein de personnes qui
peuvent trouver très intéressant
d'utiliser cette note ces plateformes
qui offrent c'est vrai une certaine
flexibilité
donc ça amène de l'indépendance aussi
pour ces personnes-là en même temps il
ya un algorithme bien sûr les données là
c'est vraiment le coeur de l'enjeu pour
que ce soit très efficace est-ce que ça
crée beaucoup de pression sur les
travailleurs
absolument il ya de plus en plus
d'études qui nous permettent de
comprendre un petit peu comment ces
plateformes fonctionne donc avec une
gestion notamment algorithmique une
gestion qui va déléguer à des
algorithmes en fait des décisions de
gestion que ce soit du recrutement de
l'évaluation de la performance même du
licenciement mais puis aussi ce sont des
algorithmes qui vont créer développer
toutes sortes d' incitatives pour
encourager des travailleurs et
travailleuses à entrer sur le système à
certains moments où c'est plus
intéressant ou non on veut un afflux par
exemple de chausseurs est donc ce sont
des algorithmes qui vont contrôler mais
aussi surveiller les travailleurs en
permanence et ian pollick de données en
tout temps oui oui tout à fait et
surveillé il ya des enjeux de
surveillance encore une fois parce que
il ya une collecte continue de donner
sur ce que sont les travailleurs s
combien de temps ils prennent pour
accepter des courses par exemple combien
de temps ils prennent pour faire leur
trajet à quelle fréquence ils refusent
des courses et est donc il ya un
encadrement très strict de
l'environnement du travail en plus des
conditions de travail qui sont
déterminés par l'algorithme alors
encadrement qui vient de l'algorithme et
qui vient donc des plateformes et est-ce
qu'un encadrement sur les conditions de
travail sur les données qui sont quand
même nombreux aussi qui sont générés sur
ces plateformes et qui sont accessibles
aux entreprises
écouter juste que justement c'est c'est
un petit peu le coeur de la bataille il
ya plusieurs enjeux mais celui là il est
central comment est ce que on peut
s'assurer que déjà concrètement on a
très peu de données fiables sur les
conditions de travail donc premier ce
que les gens gagnent effectivement après
avant dépenses combien d'heures ils
travaillent quel est le profil des gens
gpat forme refuse de communiquer ces
informations en arguant que c'est ce
sont des enjeux de compétitivité
la réalité c'est qu'on a besoin pour la
recherche mais aussi pour la législation
de connaître ces informations là on en a
besoin pour établir quel est le meilleur
encadrement possible donc jusqu'à
maintenant il ya un rapport de pouvoir
très favorable à ces plateformes qui
sait en sorte que on navigue à vue
quelle est la responsabilité de ces
plateformes en ce qui concerne justement
l'utilisation des données mais j'irai
jusqu'à la sainte et la sécurité des
travailleurs
bien justement la responsabilité elle
est très très faible pour le moment
quasi nul justement parce que ces
plateformes prétendent que les personnes
qui travaillent dessus sont des
travailleurs et travailleuses autonomes
et qu'elle donc non ce ne sont pas des
salariés qui n'ont pas droit donc aux
conditions de travail qu'on offre aux
restes des personnes par exemple au
québec ou à l'étranger récemment encore
au royaume uni il ya eu une très longue
bataille judiciaire
qui s'est soldé par une victoire des
travailleurs donc
attendre comme liebherr a été
s'est vue et exigé de reclasser les
travailleurs en salariés et donc
évidemment ça vient avec salaire minimum
à des congés etc c'est très récent ça
fait quelques mois on va voir un peu ce
qui se dégage de tout cela mais
concrètement la réalité c'est que cette
plateforme elle se dégage de toute
responsabilité vis-à-vis des
travailleurs et des remords du tout
madame de la non il y un encadrement en
fait qu'il ya des tentatives si on est
travailleur autonome dans tant qu' on
est considéré comme un travailleur
autonome on est on est simplement
responsable de cotiser y compris pour sa
retraite en cas d'invalidité est
intéressant n'est pas l'employeur qui
est responsable de cela là je répète
l'un des enjeux qu'on voit c'est que la
l'encadrement il est différent d'une
législation d'une de d'une juridiction à
une autre en fonction d'eux du statut
qui est reconnue ou pas aux travailleurs
et donc s'ils sont autonomes les les
responsabilités de la plateforme sont
minimes et ça donne ça devient presque
un positionnement compétitif pour elle
d'offrir des conditions peut-être plus
intéressante que leurs compétiteurs mais
sans obligation légale très avancé bien
c'est très intéressant on doit s'arrêter
ici merci beaucoup de nous livrer de la
nôtre d'avoir pris le temps avec nous ce
soir de regarder un peu comment
fonctionnent ces plateformes merci
monsieur fillion pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit
oh